this is a pepper panic saga level 95
video walkthrough
i'm going to play the level i'm going to
complete it and i'm going to explain
why i make the decisions that i do
um it's a difficult level for a lot of
reasons um
you only have 20 moves
you have to complete 11
patterns and they're all pretty
difficult there's no small patterns
if you haven't read the pepper panic
saga level 95 guide
on our site
um i would suggest doing that first
because that'll give you
a little bit more background into what
why i'm doing what i'm doing
and
also it's helpful because it has the
list of all the matches you need in
order and there are times when you need
to actually
avoid
making certain moves so that you won't
disrupt the pattern that you already
have
first pattern is a four pepper straight
line match of any color and that was
pretty easy to make
the next one is going to be an l so
before i make this one i want to look
around the board and see if i have an l
somewhere that i can
already put together i can see i have
the gap forward a lot of places like
here
here
in this
area but i don't have the actual
fifth pepper i need to make it
this one has it nearby
but it's a jumble of colors in the
middle where i can't bring a new one
down
so in this situation i'm just going to
make my four pepper match
and i guess since i have this one
right here
and if i make this blue four pepper
match it'll also drop a new pepper into
this area i'm gonna make it right here
all right and so that worked out we got
our l by the red pepper falling onto the
board
now the next match after this is a five
pepper match and um
one in a straight line i should say
and i don't see that anywhere so i'm
just gonna make the l and then
look over the board
now these are you know some of the
hardest uh matches to make
and
when you don't have the right gap which
is you're going to need two pairs of
peppers with a gap in the middle
most of the time since we have such low
number of moves the best thing to do is
going to be to clear out the board
so
starting a panic would be great we just
want to try to figure out the quickest
way to do that
i have a bunch of grown peppers in this
row so i'm going ahead and
explode the blue and grow all the ones
above it
with that shock wave
now i'll look things over again and see
if i if i've got the gap and if i don't
i'll just continue growing peppers to
clear out the space
i have part of the gap right here i have
two green and then i have two green that
i could bring together above it but i
don't have anything
any vertical matches that i can make in
this row to actually bring another
pepper down so i'm gonna
look around a little bit more
ideally what i'd like to do here is
explode blue pepper but i don't see
a place where i can do that
this might work
and so now we just want to wait and hope
that
we get the five pepper match in the
cascade or else there's a setup for it
whenever the peppers fall into place
and we did get it in the cascade so
that's good
now we're looking for the gap that we
need to make a tea and that'd be like a
pair of peppers
with uh the same color like
above them
and these are also very difficult to
make so you don't want to waste a lot of
moves trying to like really
set something difficult up because we'll
run out and we won't be able to finish
the level
in times like this when i i don't have
like a great match
to set up what i need i'll generally try
to find a match at the bottom of the
board
because that'll give us more action
above and more things can match and
other
opportunities can present themselves but
right now
i think i'm gonna go with this one
that'll start a small chain reaction it
won't start a pepper panic but
as you can see a lot of things will move
around the board and that setup as
things felt set up rt for us
the matches that are coming up now i
think are the hardest ones to make
because they're all one color they're
just four pepper matches but they
they have to be all the same color and
and there's just times whenever
you can't get the right color on the
board
so we'll have the first one
now we have to make oh we have the
second one too that's pretty good
you can see i could have made a tea
there and grown some some space or you
know growing some peppers around the
space or whatever but always take the
match right away if you get a chance
because
we still have five more patterns to make
and we only have 12 moves
all right so you see there's a few blue
peppers if they're all kind of spread
out on the board
we have two gaps for
um
for matching them and four in a four
pepper match but there's
really not a good way to
get another blue one down there this
will actually do it here
okay so now we need orange and
we've got that one
and we got really
fortunate to um
catch the green one in that
so now we want to look around and see if
we have
an l somewhere
i have to double check whenever i look
for these because for whatever reason
sometimes
when there's some grown peppers on the
board i have trouble seeing them
i mean the gap is pretty easy to spot
because you know you have the two pairs
that are sitting like catty corner to
each other but
for whatever reason
i uh
i try to really make sure it's not there
before i
before i um
go ahead and start clearing space
um so
it's not there anywhere i'm pretty
confident about that at this point so
what do we want to do well we want to
start
a chain reaction and green
is going to be our best color so even
though this is off to the side i'm going
to go ahead and go with this match first
because that'll that'll start a um
instant chain reaction that'll
ultimately turn into a pepper panic
and we got our l
and you can see why that
how that actually works you know what i
mean if it's not there
you have way more chance there's that
you have like it's basically like free
moves you know
and um
whenever the the pepper panics going on
and whenever the uh cascade happens so
you always want to um take that now we
we got a good setup here to make our
final match so that's great i just want
to point out that
this is what the gap but say this say
these orange weren't here this is what
the gap that you'd be looking for is
right
so in this situation if they weren't
there what i would do is i would match
this vertical orange match and that
would drop three more peppers down
and um you would just basically try to
work that way to where you could drop
one into the space and make your final
match
i'm gonna go ahead and finish the level
though because it's a you know
it's not an easy thing to do so you have
to go ahead and do it when you get your
chance but um
i hope this helps
the tips in our full guide at pepper
panic tips are you know
if you follow those you will eventually
get through this level it gives a lot of
people trouble
but most i think most of the mistakes
that people make are just that they they
spend a lot of time moving peppers
around and trying to
um
you know set things up when you just
really don't have enough moves for that
so
in those cases do what i did there just
start a chain reaction
of course look over the board and find
the way that you can do that the fastest
and then that'll give you plenty of
opportunities to try to make your
matches and set up new things
i hope this helps and i hope you finish
the level soon
thanks